the left moves to embrace abortion as a
moral good the culture wars heat up and
Democrats mull over impeachment I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show a
[Music]
lot to get to today here on the show
everything from abortion to impeachment
to homelessness just all sorts of
wonderful happy things to talk about but
first dudes summer is here Tommy John is
ready to have you looking and feeling
ready for Memorial Day barbecues and
fourth of July fireworks they will keep
you patriotic this holiday they've got
the only red white and blue underwear
collection including a USA flag print
for both men and women the collection
comes in all their best-selling fabrics
including the cool cotton fabric that
features breathable lightweight fibers
that keep you two to three times cooler
and dry four to five times faster than
regular cotton both Tommy John's men's
and women's underwear sported no wedgie
guarantee which would help me in high
school
comfortable stay put waist bands and a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft in designed to move with you Plus
now through the end of May Tommy John is
donating 5% of every purchase of select
red white and blue styles to the honor
Foundation to support veterans
transitioning to civilian life which is
awesome they're so sure you're gonna
love the fit and feel of Tommy John it's
all backed by their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee that
means if you don't love that first pair
you get a full refund Tommy John no
adjustment needed I love my Tommy John
underwear how do I know because they're
on my buttocks right now go to Tommy
John right now Tommy John's comm slash
Ben and you can save 20% on your first
order that is Tommy John comm slash Ben
for 20% off Tommy John comm slash Pat
and go check them out right now
well as the battle over abortion law in
Georgia heats up it is amazing to watch
as many on the Left have shifted their
perspective on abortion itself they've
moved away from the 1990s formulation
safe legal and rare toward a new
formulation good plentiful and happy and
the idea here is that abortion is in
fact a moral good in fact there's an
article in The New Yorker today that is
titled abortion is morally good which is
a fairly amazing statement it's by a
woman named Sarah Jones and the article
abortion is morally good what is the
argument for why abortion is morally
good well the argument is basically that
it helps women that oh those who are in
that those who aren't interested in
stopping abortion
interested in maximizing female pain
that that those who are attempting to
protect the lives of the unborn quote
weigh the suffering of women against the
prospective life of the fetus and favor
of the fetus in the end well that's true
but why would that make abortion morally
good
well writes this writer I've never
needed an abortion but I've been in an
abusive relationship and I think still
of all the ways it could have been worse
for me I could have gotten pregnant and
I think that would have killed me well
you might have had a say in it you
weren't in the relationship were you not
and your creation of a new human life
would not the killing of that life would
not be justified by the fact that you
made a choice to be in a bad
relationship
this writer says I was a 22 year old
student at a Christian university that
expelled students for having sex outside
the Holy bonds of hetero matrimony
what's amazing was that this woman
admits she was in an abusive
relationship but she's very angry at the
Christian university that is trying to
uphold the standard that says you should
not be in abusive relationships just I
was suicidally depressed when I look
back at myself across the valley of a
decade I'm still surprised to be alive I
think of the people I knew then and how
so many of them would have told me to
carry a baby to term even if it
destroyed me well yes I mean I think
that a lot of people would have
suggested that you should carry the baby
to term because again the life of the
baby means something here and if you
were going to commit suicide right if
you were actually suicidal then the vast
majority of people who are pro-life
would suggest that that is a case in
which the mother's life is in danger as
pregnancy would've been a punishment not
a miracle nothing I lived through will
convince an Alabama Republican to change
his mind to them nothing I've done in my
31 years on earth none of my
accomplishments and none of my happiness
elevates my worth above that of an
embryo well know your worth as a human
being as if in your life were being
endangered versus that of the embryo
your life would take precedence but your
worth your feelings your accomplishments
your subjective feeling of happiness yes
that does not take precedence over a
human life correct that is true
but she says abortion is a moral good
and unfortunately this is a line that
has been picked up by the left and if
it's such a mistake by the left honestly
like as a matter of politics it's a
mistake safe legal and rare was a
formulation that at least most Americans
could feel okay about I mean pro-life
Americans were going
to oppose it anyway but people who are
on the fence could at least feel like
yeah abortion it's not great but I still
wanted to be there it at least made them
feel a little bit more sanguine about
about legalizing abortion because the
suggestion was that no one would take
abortion so frivolously as to simply
have an abortion out of convenience and
thus because people were weighing
abortion as moral quandary then their
final decision shouldn't be left up to
the state it should be left up to them
now I think that's wrong obviously but
that argument has at least a little bit
more moral tether to it than the
argument that is being made now the
argument being made now by the radical
left is that abortion is fundamentally
good that depriving people of abortion
is depriving them not only of a right
but of something that benefits them and
has no consequences has no has no
downside now the truth is that this is a
line that's been pushed by radical
feminists for a very long time Gloria
Allred was speaking at a rally yesterday
in New York City when she described
pre-roll America as women's Vietnam
which is an unbelievable statement and
it's an unbelievable stamp tens of
thousands of Americans died in Vietnam
hundreds of thousands of Americans were
wounded in Vietnam how in the world was
saying that women should bear children
in their body how is that exactly
a Vietnam leg situation here's Gloria
Allred making that radical argument the
girls who have to get a back-alley
abortion and who are going to be left to
die it was our women's Vietnam more
women died or were maimed before roe v
wade by illegal abortions than men ever
died in Vietnam we thank our brave men
for their sacrifices we can never thank
them enough but we also we're hurt by
these laws which forced us into no-win
situations okay that is just a lie okay
the lie though that tens of thousands of
women were dying in back-alley abortions
it is in fact a lie there are CDC
statistics that exist from that time
period and they were suggesting the
number of women who are dying in illegal
abortions it was in the hundreds at most
and not the tens of thousands and even
so the fact is that any law
is going to have consequences for people
who break the law and attempting to
violate that law is going to be more
difficult and more dangerous than if the
law did not exist in the first place I
also want to point out here that an
argument that is constantly made by
feminists is that abortion legalizing
abortion is what allowed women to live
productive healthy lives and be part of
the work force in all of us this is a
chart from the government is the from
the Department of Labor and it shows the
civilian labor force in the United
States by sex the second half of the
chart if you can see it shows the share
of the civilian labor force by sex and
what you see here is that that green
line on the bottom chart is the share of
the female workforce okay so what
percentage of the workforce is female
and what you see is that in 1960 is
about 25 percent and then it rises
continuously and steadily that's
actually in 1950 rather it rises
continuously and steadily until about
1980 and then it ceases to grow and
women represent slightly slightly under
50% of the workforce as of right now
basically women have achieved near
parity with men in terms of the
workforce by the way the male's share of
the workforce has been declining
steadily since 1950 what you do not see
here is a massive escalation in females
in the workforce circa 1973 1975 with
the legalization of abortion in fact you
see that the rate of women in the
workforce begins to slow after that
point so the notion that taient that it
was abortion that allowed women to get
out of the house and go get a job it's
just not true it's just not true
now abortion may mean that some women
are able to not have to support a baby
while going to work but that does not
change the the overall impact of
abortion law which has not been to
stymie women from getting into the
workforce obviously this chart
demonstrates that full-scale nonetheless
the argument again is being made by the
left that abortion is not just something
that is is an unfortunate and
unfortunate part of life which is an
argument that the left used to make now
it is an affirmative good it is
something that is affirmative ly good
and we can judge you morally based on
how you feel about abortion if you are
willing to say that a woman should be
able to kill a baby in her womb at any
time this means that you are properly
woke and properly feminist Erich swallow
running a bizarre campaign for the
presidency in which I guess he needs to
keep the support of his immediate family
in this race maybe his wife I believe is
his only voter Eric's wahwah he was
speaking at an pro-abortion rally
outside the Supreme Court and I'm not
gonna say it's pro-choice because this
is legitimately pro-abortion I mean
these are people who are saying that
abortion is a moral good abortion is a
positive it is not just a decision that
somebody has to make it is a moral good
here's Eric SWA well saying that sure he
has kids but if his wife had decided to
kill his kids in the womb well he would
have had no say about that
my wife Brittany also wants you to know
we've got two beautiful children Nell
city cricket but the decision to have
children was her choice we're gonna
March with them we're gonna link arms
with them that's an amazing statement
right then that he has two beautiful
children with his wife but if she had
decided to kill those babies in the womb
well then that would have been fine with
him because he is a male feminist can
you imagine him telling that to his his
kids he has a daughter I think and he
mentions her there does he think that
that is going to make her proud to be a
feminist he's like yeah you know honey I
hope they use have beautiful dreams also
if your mother had murdered you in the
womb that would have been her choice and
whoa dad what the what what the hell and
then it got even worse jackie speier
who's a congresswoman from California
Democrat she got up at that exact same
rally and she bragged about having an
abortion and the crowd cheered her this
is a sign of moral development this is
like when Lena Dunham the actress from
girls when she came out and she said she
wished she had had an abortion it's a
rite of passage in American life at this
point I mean this isn't this is
barbarity this is pagan istic barbarity
here is jackie speier talking about how
she had an abortion and women clapping
for her and cheering for her bravery
stunning bravery and killing a child in
the womb
[Music]
I am one of the 1 and poor women in this
country who have had an abortion
[Applause]
we are wives we are mothers we are
sisters whoo I had an abortion whoo I
mean huge crowds of people cheering for
I had an abortion can you imagine any
other crime would I hit a person and
then ran it was great it was a
hit-and-run whoo well what in the world
but if this is the moral if this is the
moral conflict the Democrats choose that
it's not merely that abortion is an
unfortunate choice some people have to
make but it's an affirmative good I
think the vast majority of Americans are
not interested in this particular
version of morality we'll get to more of
this in just a second again these are
mainstream democratic figures and I'll
show you some more mainstream Democratic
figures doing the same thing and saying
that you should pay for abortion by the
way but first did you have a long day at
work a tough day at school you still
stuck at the office treat yourself to
the meal you deserve on demand from your
favorite restaurant restaurants come to
you with door - I use door - all the
time now my wife is working on a really
rough rotation that means that she is
not home very often at night and that
also means that I'm in trouble because
our kitchen is now being renovated which
means I don't have any capacity to cook
food for the kids that means I'm
ordering out a lot and I can't leave the
house I got the kids
that's where doordash comes in Jordache
connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city ordering is
easy just use the door - app choose what
you want to eat - or we'll bring it to
you anywhere you are not only is that
burger place you love on tour - already
over three hundred and ten thousand
other amazing restaurants are - door -
connects you with door to door delivery
in over 3,300 cities all 50 states in
Canada choose from your local go-to s or
choose from your favorite chains like
Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a Cheesecake
Factory
don't worry about dinner let dinner come
to you with door - right now our
listeners can get five bucks off your
first order of $15 or more when you
download the door - happen and for promo
code Ben that's 5 bucks off your first
order when you download that door - app
from the app store and enter promo code
Ben again that is promo code Ben for 5
bucks off your first order from George -
it is indispensable in today's day and
age go check out door - right now and
use it promo code Ben on the app and get
five bucks off your first
of 15 bucks or more from door - alrighty
so mazie Hirono the senator from Hawaii
very much following in Jackie Speier
footsteps she is speaking at the same
insane rally outside the Supreme Court
and she's bragging about the fact that
she told a traitor's meaning
eleven-year-old girls that their
abortion rights were under attack
prepubescent girls she is telling that
it is deeply important that they be able
to have an abortion if they if if a
child is conceived with someone that
they are having sex with they should be
able to kill that child
mazie Hirono is bragging about that to
eighth-grade girls okay it's just it's
amazing it's amazing so Democrats are
now promoting is an affirmative good the
ability to get an abortion not just that
they want you to pay for it so this is
the next step now Joe Biden is as a guy
running for president trying to shake
his non woe credentials the fact is that
Joe Biden has held a series of positions
over the years that are not in line with
the radical segments of his base which
for the money is the reason why he is a
front-runner in the Democratic
nomination process right now it's it's
amazing to watch Joe Biden is only a
front-runner right now because he
appears moderate and people in the
Democratic Party are looking at Biden
they're saying what if we just ran a
moderate who doesn't look completely
crazy against Donald Trump to win and
that's a huge person that's a plurality
of the Democratic base by leaps and
bounds and yet Biden in an effort to
stave off opposition from his radical
left compatriots he is now shifting on
positions that he has held for years so
for years Joe Biden said that he was
against public funding for abortion he
was in favor of the so-called Hyde
Amendment that banned public funding for
abortions if you want to have an
abortion that would be a you issue this
what Joe Biden used to say then we'll
show you Joe Biden reversing himself in
the last 48 hours you still oppose the
public funding for abortion
I still am opposed to public funding to
abortion and the reason I am is again it
goes to the question of whether or not
you are going to impose a view to
support something that is not a
guaranteed right but an affirmative
action to promote okay this is Joe
Biden's old position then he was asked
specifically by the ACLU whether as
president he would lift the Hyde
Amendment which bans federal insurance
coverage of abortion and he said yes and
then he came out with a video talking
about how wonderful Roe vs. Wade is and
how it is imperative that roe v-- wade
be enshrined in law forever a law of the
land is roe v wade it lays out a
constitutional guarantee that women can
in fact make a choice between she and
her doctor in circumstances laid out in
a row it's guaranteed constitutionally
now and what this is all about is trying
to make get an appeal to the Supreme
Court in the hope that the conservative
justice the president has has in fact
put on the court two of them will vote
to overrule over over the role of the
roe v wade the law of the land it's
wrong it must be stopped
this is a choice under Roe between a
woman and her doctor' well between a
woman and her doctor'
and taxpayers who have to pay for it
according to the new version of Joe
Biden it's not just Joe Biden who is
saying this Kirsten Gillibrand who again
has more positions on the issues than
the kamasutra has Kirsten Gillibrand the
senator from New York she was asked well
why exactly should we pay for your
abortion for example and she says it's
not your decision whether to fund
abortion the government should fund
abortion so this is the new democratic
party position on this thing what would
you say to taxpayers out there who say
look I support everyone having their own
freedoms but that when it comes to my
tax dollars abortion isn't something
that I want to support I do not believe
that that is a valid argument I think
that the Hyde Amendment should be
repealed and that we actually need to
make sure that women regardless of their
income level have a basic right to
reproductive care it's about our
humanity and it's about our basic civil
rights and so I will work to repeal the
Hyde Amendment
I would also work to codify roll bro v
Wade and I would work to guarantee that
no matter what state you live in you
will have access to a full range of
reproductive services
I mean this is an amazing move by the
Democratic Party they used to understand
that the best solution for the
Democratic Party was some level of
moderation on this particular issue not
anymore now it's such an affirmative
good that you and I are supposed to fund
abortions ourselves that it is a basic
right in America owning a gun not a
basic right paying for somebody else's
abortion is something that you must do
they have a right to your money to pay
for the killing of their unborn child I
mean it's an amazing statement cory
booker is saying the same thing the
senator from new jersey running for
president this is not nut picking okay
this is not us finding nuts in the
democratic party saying crazy things
these are all mainstream elected members
of the democratic party saying this
stuff must be relearned in every
generation
[Applause]
yeah public taxpayer funding of abortion
I love that he describes the killing of
the unborn that he described snuffing
out human life as luxuriating and the
blessings of others struggle I'm glad
you'll get to I mean that is the
definition of abortions that you are
luxuriating in the in the blessings of
the struggle of the unborn that you are
reaping the benefits presumably of
killing something that is not you it's
an amazing statement it's three cheers
for abortion the Democratic Party maybe
four cheers for abortion if that's even
possible and then you get the the insane
radical wing of the Democratic Party
they go so far as to suggest that this
Planned Parenthood and Planned
Parenthood representative in New York
City during a rally yesterday suggesting
that the people who pay the most when it
comes to pro-life policy our transgender
men you can't forget transgender men in
this equation we have to make sure that
that women who believe they are men are
included in all of the abortion talk
yeah that this this is all a winning
recipe I think for Democrats an order to
drive care underground but also to force
a national showdown in our Supreme Court
about access to our constitutional and
human rights and it's not just an attack
on women it's an attack on anyone who
can or might get pregnant including
transgender men and gender
non-conforming people
oh it's an attack on all of those people
- my goodness
it seems to me abortion is a pretty
obvious attack on you know the person
who's getting killed that seems like
probably the attack we might want to
focus on here now I want to talk about a
couple of bad faith arguments that are
being put out there naturally by the
op-ed pages over the New York Times in
the Washington Post there's an article
by a guy named dr. Warren Hearn who's a
physician and epidemiologist who
specializes in late term abortion
services naturally he's defending that
by saying this is the title of the
article again abortion is affirmative
good pregnancy kills abortion saves
lives the idea here is that it is more
dangerous to be pregnant than not to be
pregnant that is true you know it's the
most dangerous to the baby the killing
of the baby and you know what also makes
women safe late term would be giving
birth to the baby and then they are also
not pregnant anymore except that they
have not killed the baby but according
to this New York Times headline
pregnancy kills pregnancy get an
abortion doesn't kill pregnancy kills
also I love this perspective from the
Washington Post
men who impregnate women don't face any
consequences in the new abortion laws I
mean now you're making a case that men
should support women after they knock
them up a case of which I fully agree
this is sort of like the argument you
see from the left wall if you care so
much about babies then why aren't you in
favor of adoption quick note Alabama the
state that just banned abortion across
the board they are number one that they
set their their number one record this
year as a record for adopting foster
children Alabama families so they are in
fact caring about children after they
are born in Alabama as far as things
like foster care okay in a second I want
to get to democratic governance and the
real priorities here because it really
is someone telling first no one really
has time to go to the post office you're
busy who's got time for all that traffic
parking lugging all your mail and
packages it's a real hassle
that's why you need stamps calm it's one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses stamps calm
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office
stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps calm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
just ten it's your mail carrier or drop
it in the mailbox it is that simple with
stamps calm you get five cents off every
first class stamp it up to 40% off
Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps calm is a
no-brainer it saves you time and it
saves you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses including the Daily wire
already use stamps calm right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage ends digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on that microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro I personally
use stamps calm save me time and money
it's great go check them out stamps comm
enter Shapiro at the top of the homepage
and make sure that you get that special
deal Sam's comm enter Shapiro okay so if
you are a median voter let's say you're
a moderate voter living in say a
suburban area and you look at the
Democratic Party right now and the
Democratic Party is focused intensely on
taxpayer funding for abortion this is
their thing taxpayer funding for
abortion and also Trump is evil this is
their two-pronged pitch I have to say
that is not a very strong pitch and that
is the pitch right now the pitch is
abortion is an affirmative good and
Donald Trump is an affirmative evil and
then they send out their cultural elites
to appeal to us on this basis a late
night television has basically become a
psychiatrist couch for Hollywood stars
who can't sleep because of Trump you
know on their beds of money in the
Hollywood Hills far away from all the
problems of regular life here's julianna
margulies who's the star of what she was
the on The Good Wife and and here she is
explaining that she has problem sleeping
because of Trump you know in her giant
mansion on top of her pile of money
overlooking a city that she doesn't even
have to engage in here is julianna
margulies whining to Stephen Colbert
about this another extraordinarily
wealthy Hollywood star who doesn't have
to deal with any of the problems with
everyday life but Donald Trump keeps
them awake at night one of the things I
stopped doing was I do not read the news
at night because I I was waking up in
the middle of the night from nightmares
of just screaming I had 100 oh I know
you've read my dream diary
well I was in a boardroom there was a
long board there was a long table and it
was just the guy who's in the Oval
Office right now sitting there and I
walked in and I was screaming screaming
don't you care about the next I mean I
was going crazy and screaming at him and
yelling and that was 2016 and I woke up
in a sweat and I went oh my god I've
gone insane and I have to stop reading
the news at night okay so this is the
pitch the pitch is that Donald Trump
wakes up Hollywood actresses in the
middle of the night because it's a bad
orange man with weird hair that's the
pitch and also abortion is immoral good
that's a hell of a pitch that is one
hell of a pitch because let's be real
about this I live in a democratic
governance state I live in a democratic
governance city and it has turned into a
trash heap it has turned into a trash
heap if you want to look at democratic
governance right now if you want to look
at people who are living in the suburbs
and worrying about what their life is
going to look like I guarantee you they
care far less about julianna margulies
his sleep patterns and far more about
the fact that their cities have turned
into hot garbage
this is a clip from NBC Los Angeles
today talking about the homeless problem
in Los Angeles got 65,000 homeless
people living on the streets of Los
Angeles which has been Democratic
governor for nigh on two decades at this
point in a state that has democratic
majorities in both houses and the
Democratic governor and the city has
turned into a garbage pit I've lived
here my entire life I've lived here my
entire life and I can tell you from
personal experience that the the
problems of the city's turning into
trash heaps is not a mild problem it
started off in places like Skid Row or
at least was relatively contained and
now it has spread out into suburban
areas I live in a suburban area in the
last four years we have found several
open needles on the street maybe three
weeks ago there was a obvious heroin
addict who is lying face down in the
gutter in the middle of a residential
area thought the guy was Edgar Allan Poe
I mean who's lying face down in the
gutter in a residential area and the
city can do nothing about it why because
Democrats who govern the city have
refused to do anything about it in the
name of the freedom of people -
apparently pollute public areas but
don't worry my tax payer dollars aren't
going to fund you know my neighborhood
being livable and my children being able
to walk outside without fear of step
an open needle they're going toward
taxpayer funding of abortions that's
where Democratic priorities are here's a
clip from NBC Los Angeles talking about
the problem in LA but of course nobody
in LA will ever consider maybe it's the
people in charge who are the problem
you're getting a bird's eye view of LA's
most notorious trash pile it's in
downtown on Sarah's Avenue right between
the fashion and produce districts day
and night this spot and countless others
are magnets for rats that could carry
fleas infected with typhus and other
diseases this national survey now ranks
la as the second most rat infested city
in the nation
one reason experts say heaps of
uncollected trash at hundreds of
homeless encampments where people are
literally living in piles of garbage
they're literally living in piles of
garbage is NBC okay mici is not a
right-wing source people are living in
piles of garbage you know why they're
living in piles of garbage I have a lot
of friends on the police force in LAPD
and when they get a call that somebody
is loitering
they are basically told by the
higher-ups that they need to ignore this
they're not allowed to rouse people
they're not allowed to move people
they're not allowed to arrest people
they're not even because of an ACLU
lawsuit they're not even allowed to
remove shopping carts full of garbage
that attract fleas and rats they're not
allowed to remove those those are
considered the personal property of
homeless people who are who are living
on public property right this very
instant okay this is not a lack of
sympathy for homeless folks hey this is
a lack of sympathy for politicians who
refuse to do anything to make their
cities livable I have a right to the
sidewalk that I pay for you do not have
a right to sleep on the sidewalk outside
of my front outside of my front door two
years ago there was an it two years ago
I recall this vividly I used to do a
morning show here in Los Angeles and the
men tied to get a you know inordinately
early in order do so it's like 5:15 in
the morning I have to get up and I have
to go do the morning show and I look
outside and right outside of our front
door there is a homeless person who is
riding a bicycle and he has two shopping
carts full of trash behind him and he
and the front wheel has come off of his
bicycle and he's right outside our front
door and so I'm concerning I've
I have a couple of little kids I'm
concerned about leaving my house with
this person right outside of the guy is
you know this is one of the big issues
with a lot of homeless folks a lot of
them are drug addicts and a lot of them
are mentally ill a heavy percentage
according to E Fuller Tory who's written
extensively about mental illness at
least a plurality maybe the majority of
the homeless people in the in major
cities are suffering from some form of
severe mental illness so I call the
police and the police take 35 40 minutes
to respond this is not a priority call
and the reason it's not a priority call
is because they have been told basically
that they are not to do anything about
these problems so I sit there waiting
inside my door for this homeless person
to move on because I don't want to get
into a confrontation with the person and
this person then gets angry precedes to
take a crowbar out of one of the
shopping cars and starts beating the
hell out of his bike in front of our
front door eventually the police arrive
and move him along but this is what
major cities are becoming okay and I'm
living a fairly nice residential area
Skid Row in Los Angeles is actually a
breeding ground for actual disease it's
a breeding ground for disease we are
seeing third world diseases returned to
the United States in major cities
because politicians have made it a
priority not to do anything about these
problems and it is not just in Los
Angeles it is in San Francisco it is in
Washington DC is it in it's in New York
City it's in Seattle I stood to a show
up in Seattle local show up in Seattle
Seattle is a beautiful city except it's
been made into a homeless encampment by
a series of Democratic mayor's who have
decided that they can do nothing about
people living out in the in the open
I'll talk in a second about what some
actual solutions would look like to this
problem but if Democrats are going to
make the case that they ought to run
things then how about we look at where
they run things and see how things are
going cuz it turns out they've turned my
city into a rat infested crap hole they
have turned Los Angeles into I mean the
the quality of life in Los Angeles for
taxpayers has declined markedly and that
is due to mayor Garcetti and Mayor
Villaraigosa it is due to government
Gavin Newsom and Governor Jerry Brown it
is due to democratic governance in this
city and in this state I'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about that suit that you're
wearing so I know you just went down to
the local department store you figured
oh you know an off-the-rack suit that'll
look nice it doesn't looks terrible
instead what you
need is a made-to-measure suit for you
Indo Chino is the world's most exciting
made-to-measure menswear company they
make suits and shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort if you're in the middle of
planning a wedding they have tons of
options for those looking to outfit
their wedding party
I love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and colors to choose
from here's how it works you can visit a
stylist at one of their showrooms Indo
Chino has over 40 showrooms in North
America alone and they will take your
measurements personally or you can
measure at home and shop online at Indo
Chino com choose your fabric your design
customizations simply submit your
measurements with your choices online
and then relax while your suit gets
professionally tailored and mailed to
you in a couple of weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium in zou
Chino suit for just 379 bucks at Indo
Chino calm when you enter Shapiro's at
checkout as 50% off the regular price
for a made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free that's Indo Chino calm
promo code Shapiro for any premium suit
for just 379 bucks and free shipping
it's an incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit once you go custom
you don't go back my favorite suit is an
Indo Chino suit that I got at the endo
Chino headquarters here in Santa Monica
it's just fabulous it's a lot better
than anything you can get off the rack
go check them out at Indo Chino com
promo code Shapiro for any premium suit
for just 379 bucks which is a great
price and free shipping ok we're gonna
get to more of democratic governance and
why for people quality of life may Trump
julianna margulies and Robert De Niro's
hatred for president Trump first I need
to remind you our business here at daily
wire is growing rapidly thank God which
means we are excited to be offering more
opportunities to become part of our
in-house team have you ever dreamt of
working here well let me inform you
first of all it will not match up to
your dreams but if you still want to
work here
they shouldn't head on over to Daly
wire.com slash careers and see if any of
our job openings would be right for you
or somebody that you know if you're
interested in being paid a pittance to
do extraordinarily hard labor on a show
that you love check out Daly where slash
careers and see how it goes for you I
mean we are looking for folks and we
have a lot of careers oh it actually is
a pretty good police to work you can
talk to any of the people here they'll
tell you that and if they don't I'll
fire them check it out over at Daly wire
comm slash careers also please subscribe
over at daily wired I come you don't
want to work here but you do want to
support what we do $9.99 a month gets
you subscription to daily wire calm when
you do to get two additional hours of
meat of my show every single day you
also get Andrew Clavin show you get Matt
Walsh's show you get michael molzof will
show you get also
sorts of great stuff and one bad thing
if you subscribe over it's a Lee Weyer
calm if you get the annual subscription
for 99 bucks a year you get this the
leftist here is hot or cold tumbler go
check it out right now it is overflowing
these days all you have to do is go
subscribe also and there are all sorts
of benefits get the Sunday special early
a day early it gets the sending letters
to the mailbag maybe get a chance to win
and come out to watch a daily wire
backstage we have all sorts of good and
those goodies are going to increase
markedly in the coming months so you
want to be a member it's really cool
also go check us out at YouTube or
iTunes subscribe leave us a review we
were ranked by by one of the pod track
services as the second biggest podcast
in America last month make us number one
go subscribe at YouTube or iTunes tell
your friends about it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so as I'm talking about democratic
governance has been a disaster area a
full-on disaster area in America's major
cities from Detroit to New York to
Washington DC to Los Angeles and what's
their solution what's the solution to
making life unlivable for taxpayers
raising taxes but making the streets
less safe raising taxes but not fixing
the pots but not fixing the potholes and
then stumping to pay for abortions what
has been the the the response by
governor Gavin Newsom our
forward-thinking governor here in the
state of California well he says you
know homelessness is a problem in
California he's got a solution you know
what it is a task force you know if we
just have a bunch of people Blue Ribbon
task force that they'll sit around
they'll talk about things then they'll
issue a white paper that they'll do
nothing about Gavin Newsom used to be
the mayor of San Francisco you know what
he did when he was mayor of San
Francisco he pledged to end homelessness
in San Francisco has homelessness been
ended in San Francisco well there's an
article in The Washington Post today
called Hal San Francisco broke America's
hearts no he's not end homelessness in
San Francisco and multiplied rapidly
under him now he's the governor of the
state but he's got an idea it's a task
force guys the last count we had twenty
four percent of the nation's homeless is
mayor Shaw said the number that are
unsheltered is substantially higher than
that it's a state challenge that
manifests in cities and counties large
and small and as a consequence that
requires leadership at all levels this
task force this work group of leaders
will organize a framework of specific
and prescriptive goals at all levels and
with those goals we will advance our
efforts at the state level to help fund
and access the resources to achieve
those goals we got work to do this is a
national disgrace yeah you are a
national disgrace er I'm sorry you and
democratic governance in this state are
a national disgrace the homelessness
problem
in San Francisco in Los Angeles
increasingly in San Diego now across
across democratic areas in big cities is
a national disgrace again I talked to
people who are on the neighborhood
councils I talked to the LAPD they
cannot there every major Park in the Los
Angeles area
has been overrun with home
Hammond's every single one you cannot
let your kids play in a major park
unsupervised in Los Angeles
you just cannot it's insane and that is
a result of Democrats who have decided
to go along to get along with the ACLU
and have declared that you have a right
to sleep in your car you have a right to
sleep on the street you have a right to
do all this stuff now how would you
actually solve the homelessness problem
well the homeless break down into a
bunch of separate categories by the way
I just want to point out the New York
Times has a piece today bill de blasio
the mayor of New York I'll get to the
solutions when it comes to homelessness
in just one second first I just want to
mention this bill de blasio
wants to run for president of the United
States here's an article from the New
York Times today rats are taking over
New York City
the city that he runs why because it
just like in LA
nobody's collecting the garbage that is
the reason that rats are taking over the
city of New York in New York says the
New York Times rats once scurried in the
shadows but now they frolic brazenly in
broad daylight
mr. de Blasio calling for more rat
corpses unveiled a 32 million-dollar
assault on rats in 2017 which included
increased litter basket pickups
deployment of solar powered trash
compacting bins and rat resistant steel
cans the city has also used dry ice to
smother rats where they live but rath
sightings are on the upswing anyway why
because nobody is still picking up the
trash city health inspections found
31,000 instances of active rat signs
including sightings and droppings at
buildings and properties last year
nearly double the instances in 2014 a
major contributing factor according to
the New York Times is how the city
collects trash bags are left outside on
the curb for hours before pick up the
next morning it's just an all-night
buffet for the rats says Jason Munchie
south a biology professor at Fordham
University who has led rat safaris to
observe the vermin in Columbus Park in
Chinatown Michel Deutsch an entomologist
with the arrow exterminating on Long
Island said there's no magic bullets
reducing rats he can't just go in and
order an air strike and then leave rat
populations can rebound unless you are
always pressing them and by the way one
thing that contributes to this is open
trash is people living in trash it's all
of this is a good indicator that maybe
if you are concerned about the future of
your community if you're concerned about
thymes we're not turning back
and what it was during the 1970s and 80s
under people like Ed Koch and David
Dinkins if instead maybe you'd like I
don't know a cleaned-up area of New York
if you would like a Los Angeles that
looks at least in terms of clean streets
more like it did a couple of decades ago
and less like homeless people on every
bench I mean it's basically that there
was an old political slogan a chicken in
every pot okay Los Angeles can promise
you Los Angeles can promise you that
there will be a homeless person on every
bench it was that was the Herbert Hoover
campaign slogan in 1928 a chicken in
every pot and a car in every garage in
Los Angeles de prata the promise is if
you pay enough tax payer dollars
there'll be a homeless person on every
bench and open needles on every street
corner in San Francisco it's poop on
every street corner human poop on every
street corner by the way it's funny I
was talking with Newt Gingrich the other
day and the former Speaker pointed out
that in San Francisco you got a $300
fine if your dog craps on the corner and
you don't pick it up if you're a human
you crap on the corner you get nothing
so if you own a dog your best solution
is to let your dog crap on the corner
and then just claim it was you if the
police stopped by to find you or
something okay so what exactly could be
done with regard to the homeless problem
if people actually had the stones to do
it first of all you have to break down
the homeless problem into several
categories who are the homeless okay now
the reason there are two problems here
and you want to solve both of them okay
but what's funny is that the left ones
to ignore one of them completely so the
two problems are this the actual
problems of the homeless how do you help
homeless people in a sympathetic way how
do you help them people who are heroin
addicts people who are severely mentally
ill people who are suffering from
temporary economic downturns how do you
help those people that is problem one
and then there is a second problem which
is not irrelevant and the people who
pointed out are not bad people
there are good people who would like to
see their taxpayer dollars used in a
proper way and who would like to live in
safe communities hey the second problem
is the impact of homeless people on
every Park bench on every street corner
shooting up in doorways leaving open
needles on the street pooping on street
corners it is not irrelevant that there
are externalities to homelessness and
one of the things that members of many
and many members of the political left
have done is they have said that if you
call the cops on a homeless person who's
outside your front door beating the crap
out of his bicycle with a crowbar that
you're a part of the problem now
because now you've called in the
authorities and don't you
sympathy for these homeless people I can
have sympathy for someone and still
recognize that when you are infringing
on the public space that I paid for you
do not have a right to do that and you
are making my community worse it is a
community in which I live and I pay
taxes and I raise my children and you do
not have a right to make that community
worse both of these problems can be
handled but it means getting serious and
yes it means some consequences for a
certain group particularly of homeless
people so let's take the homeless
problem as an example in terms of
governance as I say there are four types
I think four types of who most people
one they're the severely mentally ill
those people do not have a right to live
on the street
those people need to be
institutionalized if you are a
schizophrenic who is living on the
streets and storing I mean there's an
article in the in The New York Times
today or actually it in the Huffington
Post rather a couple years ago I think
about the homelessness issue if you are
a if you are a severely schizophrenic
person who takes your unemployment or
welfare check and you stash and you
stash wads of cash around the city
because you're schizophrenic and
mentally ill we are not doing you any
good by allowing you to do that we need
to make it easier to institutionalize
people who are severely mentally ill you
are doing mentally ill people no favors
by allowing them to live in their own
filth on city streets I don't know when
this became sympathy it's insane and if
that means more public funding of mental
health facilities that's what it means
good fine I've been calling for that for
years by the way and I'm a libertarian
okay so there's that
that's the severely mentally ill then
you have the problem of people who are
addicted heroin addicts and here the
answer is that if you are a heroin
addict you do not have a right to live
on the street so you will be arrested
for loitering and you will be arrested
for trespassing and then instead of
being jailed you will be put into a
clean-out program we will and we will
fund those clean-out programs we will
make sure that you can go to a CLE and
if you refuse to abide by that if you go
back to living on the street then you
will be jailed there are consequences to
doing this sort of thing then there are
people who just want to live on the
street no matter what they just feel
like they have a right to live on the
street in Los Angeles many of those
people claim that they their jobs won't
pay for rent they won't pay for an
apartment and the answer to that is
here's money for a bus ticket right you
can if you live on the street you can be
arrested and if not here's a bus ticket
you can leave because if the question is
I can't afford to live here then
should not be living here we're not
talking about mentally ill people we're
not talking about addicts we're talking
about sane people who have decided they
would rather live in their car in Los
Angeles then go get a job somewhere else
and live in an apartment you don't have
a right to do that
so we'll pay for your bus ticket so you
can leave because if you can't afford to
live here you should not be living here
and then finally there are the
chronically homeless who are kind of
Inbetweeners you know people who may
have mental issues but are not
significantly a danger to themselves or
others people who are incapable of
holding down a job and they're if you
have to build more public housing
facilities you build more public housing
facilities if you have to open more
shelters you open more shelters this is
the way that you would handle the
problem but yes you do have to give
police the ability to move people you do
have to give police the ability to take
people's crap that is in a stolen
shopping cart away from them you have to
pay attention to quality of life issues
and that doesn't mean shuffling them
over into the poorer areas of Los
Angeles and leaving them there it means
that every area of Los Angeles should be
free of people who are living on the
streets you do not have a right to live
on the streets and if people choose to
live outside the borders of Los Angeles
in homeless encampments then that
becomes the local authorities issue
there but instead what we've gotten from
the left is its unsympathetic its
NIMBYism to say I don't want a homeless
person shooting up heroin outside my
front gate okay then call me an inmate
fine and call most Americans that way
because it turns out you know what we'd
like we'd like clean neighborhoods we'd
like neighborhoods where our kids can
walk we would like neighborhoods where
there isn't open crap and open needles
on the street and if Democrats won't do
that and they're too focused on weeping
over Donald Trump being president and
they're too focused on what Alabama
chooses to do to protect human life and
if they're great governing suggestion is
that we have to make sure the taxpayer
dollars are used not to clean up city
streets but to ensure that a woman who
has sex with a guy and then gets
pregnant can pay for the killing of that
unborn child that's where my taxpayer
dollars are supposed to go then you know
what run on that run on that and see how
you do by the way Republicans are fools
if they do not run on these public
safety issues they're fools absolute
fools whether there's a gubernatorial
candidate in California he was running
as a Republican several years ago and
the homelessness problem was
already an issue there's also something
called prison realignment that was
pursued by Governor Jerry Brown in which
he basically released criminals into the
public square
by reclassifying felonies as
misdemeanors and then sending
misdemeanor prisoners over to local
jails that would not hold them and I
said to this Republican candidate I do
not understand for the life of me why
you are not running on quality of life
and safety and she says no I'm gonna run
on education so then you're an idiot of
course you should be running on public
on quality of life and and safety issues
by the way Donald Trump should as well
Donald Trump should be running on this
problem he should be pointing out that
Seattle which is a gem of a city is
being turned into a giant Hooverville
you should point out that San Francisco
is being turned into a stratified
society where if you can afford to you
live on the penthouse level and you
never have to deal with the homeless
encampments and then if you can't then
you're homeless it should be Republicans
pointing this stuff out and proposing
solutions and yes that obviously is
going to involve the the ability of the
police to at least move people that
doesn't mean that means police have to
be trained and how to deal with mentally
ill people they have a rough job the
police do and we have to take that into
account or we have to form new forces of
people who are specifically designed to
deal with mentally ill people or addicts
and they have to have the authority to
move people and they have to have the
authority to call in the police
to arrest someone if they're violating
the law but Democrats don't want to
handle any of these issues they want to
throw up their hands and declare that
it's unsympathetic to handle any of
these issues well guess what most
Americans don't consider themselves
unsympathetic if they wish to live in a
place where their kids can run around
free just tell me where a higher crying
over over Donald Trump's election though
Democrats make sure that it makes sure
that you focus in on that okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like as you
know I am a huge baseball fan and
there's a great baseball book that came
out a couple weeks ago by Tyler Kepner
who's a baseball writer over at the New
York Times it's called K a history of
baseball in ten pitches K obviously is
the the scorecard sign for a strikeout
and it's just great it's got all sorts
of anecdotal anecdotal stories wonderful
little tidbits data about ten pitches
everything from the fork ball to the to
the split finger and fastball did it's
just it's just great if you're a
baseball fan it's really one of the
better baseball books that I've read
recently
Tylar kepner's a.k.a history of baseball
in ten pitches go check that out right
now okay now time for a couple of things
that I hate okay thing that I hate
number one I kind of love it
I'll be honest like I kind of love this
Kamala Harris is being a softball
questions by CNN because this is how it
goes if you're a Democrat you never get
asked by CNN if you're a Republican what
your favorite song is or how you thought
of the Game of Thrones finale but if
you're a Democrat you get asked these
questions all the time watch as Senator
Kamala Harris who I don't know she when
God when God distributed the awkward
from his jar of awkward in the creation
of human beings
he used a heavy dose on Hillary Clinton
and he used what was left over in
Camille Harris here's Carmel Harris
being incredibly awkward about a pretty
simple question do you have a favorite
band or a favorite musician I'd say one
of my favorites is Bob Marley good
choice you can't go wrong with that
that's a crowd-pleaser on your mixtape
what would be like your favorite three
songs oh okay let's see
I read the Franklin anything read the
Franklin I would say Bob Marley and then
I don't know I love cardi B she says
Lord laughs and and I love that I love
that the anchor there's like I asked you
for your favorite songs and you just
gave me so who's your favorite singer
slash artist Bob Marley who's your
favorite song Bob Marley strong answer
they're from from Senator Harris who by
the way has just been a dud as a
candidate you would have expected her to
be growing by leaps and bounds right
she's the most intersectional candidate
in the field nope she has been a giant
fail from launch effective now maybe
that changes but she is not nearly the
talented politician a lot of people
thought that she was going to be I mean
she's had her Thunder stolen by people
who to judge what does that say about
her and meanwhile Democrats are calling
for impeachment but they are split on it
so this is kind of humorous so Democrats
don't know whether they want to impeach
President Trump or whether they don't
want to impeach a president Trump and
this is leading to a split in the
Democratic soul you ends up with james
Clyburn the the House Majority Whip
saying that a majority of Democrats are
actually no on impeachment
if you did a secret ballot among the
Democratic caucus yes or no an
impeachment
what would the majority likely be oh the
majority would be no if you like that's
big
yes I do it's not as big a majority
today Oh yesterday yesterday but a
majority will be for stay instead a
stand focus stay on what we're doing
because this thing is moving in our
direction
okay so it's pretty amazing even the
house leadership Pelosi Clyburn like no
we're not gonna do that then you have a
OC who's like yeah we should totally
impeach him because what does she care
she's from a heavy blue district
I trust the speaker's taking a measured
approach to ensure that we're moving
everyone forward I know that you know
being a speaker is hard holding this
party together is a difficult task but I
think that we know what we need to do I
personally believe that I think we have
to move forward we have to move forward
according to AOC and of course according
to representative Sheila jackson-lee who
also says she's yes on impeachment so
prepare for the battle inside the
Democratic Party this should be fun to
watch today in the next 48 hours I'll be
introducing a resolution of
investigation the opening comments in
that resolution says that the Judiciary
Committee will investigate whether
sufficient grounds exist for the House
of Representatives to exercise the power
by article 1 section 2 Clause 5 of the
Constitution and respect to acts of
impeachment of the President of the
United States okay so I'm gonna have to
ask her um what exactly is the ground is
there is there a charge on the
impeachment like what what exactly is
the grounds other than you hate Trump
it'll be amusing to watch Democrats run
in 2020 on Trump should be impeached and
we don't know why and also abortion is
awesome make that your platform please
I dare you go for it all right we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content this is why
should subscribe either we'll see you
later today or we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show Donald Trump is doing
everything he can to force the Democrats
to play out their impeachment fantasies
right here in reality where they'll make
them look like idiots Nancy Pelosi knows
it can't do a damn thing about it
sad Nancy smart trump will talk about it
on the andrew Clavin show plus the
mailbag I'm Andrew Cleveland